you've got everybody here beat no I
think you got absolutely incredible I
have this theory I was thinking about it
right they you know that phrase the the
tall the hair the closer to God
yeah so you're like el papa you're the
Pope yeah maybe that's right it's you're
saying this is like a divine this is me
communicating with God what I'm doing
with my hair right you know it's funny
you recently posted this picture I think
was probably from the show and people
thought that you had like a wig on that
is really your hair that's my hair so
it's a here's a little-known fact about
me right so if I attack my hair attacks
too separately right on its own if I
attack my hair goes away my hair my hair
says you got this and it goes to a safe
location
fair enough yeah you know this is
strange you play a teenager yeah but
you're 26
still still very young but 26 a lot of
the fans believe that you're a teenager
so you're constantly getting being
invited to proms is that right yeah I've
gotten asked to quite a bit of problems
in last year's that's that's probably
got to be a little awkward you explained
to them yeah it's not really good
there's not a lot of interaction but
I've learned yeah that's probably a good
idea that's always been my mistake as I
write back then they write and then we
start you know I think so this is I
heard the last with with Ashton so you
need a legal team I need a legal top
yeah why the Netflix legal team wouldn't
be okay with that yeah yeah but I think
it's I heard this from Jamie Fox once so
they're all 17 18 right so you just got
to cultivate the fan base so I won't go
to prom but in like ten years I'll go on
a date with you right that can come off
sounding really creepy yeah guess so
yeah I guess so yeah
you